what is going on there reject nation koi
just showed up with his tony stark
facial hair rushed to pick him up
because this trailer dropped just a 15
minutes too late for us all right guys
leave a like he's the marvel expert he's
going to handle this i've got to do it
so much
[Music]
every
night i dreamed the same dream
awesome
wow
oh nice transition
that's sweet
i did what i had to do
to protect our world
you can't control everything strange
you open the doorway between universes
oh [ __ ] we don't know who or what we'll
walk through it
whole bunch of cameos
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous
he was right
it's just a minotaur hanging out
i'm sorry stephen
your desecration of realize
will not go unpunished oh [ __ ] oh dude
like ultron sentries
we should tell him the truth
[Music]
the trailer are you serious wow
oh yes
just got out of here
[Music]
that doesn't seem fair
can someone tell me what we just watched
no button this doesn't need it who needs
somebody don't look at that michael
waldron
that's patrick stewart's that is
unmistakably his voice and the
illuminati i want to sew the villain i
love it i love that she's got a point
and that's something we talked about
years ago with not wanting just like the
mad woman syndrome of like hey it's a
little hypocritical what are you doing
yeah they're just calling out in the
trailer well the fact that they go so
far is to have her confront herself in a
literal form whether that be a
multiversal variant or just her you know
in some kind of visual psychological
representation yeah and i love that we
can have even that gray area in a
trailer like this and the idea that he's
looking at his heroic self while she's
looking at her villain self the
dichotomy of how he perceives himself
and how she perceives herself she sees
it as grief he sees it as triumph i
don't care how you guys are processing
so much
where do i jump in with this
conversation i i i think that this
really demonstrated sam raimi's
direction a hell of a lot it's felt a
lot more like sam raimi film much more
than i even anticipated to actually feel
especially at the opening moments with
all of its nightmarish sequences a lot
of them spinning shots that sam raimi
loves to do and the ins and whatnot who
was that person flying at wanda earlier
on he said captain marvel it looked like
captain marvel i thought no load nova
because like the it's hard to tell but
it looked like it could be a helmet with
the nova symbol and the blue gold but it
also looked like a cosmic power-up so a
cosmic entity could fit either of those
i really do like the conversation that
they're having it looks like they're
doing so much here it's like you got
america's chavez they always happen to
look after the multiverses and chaos
that really does seem like the the
illuminat that would be the illuminati
definitely patrick stewart which could
tie into an incursion event which is how
they could tell the multiverse story so
in the incursion of it in the comics
it's other earths colliding from other
universes if you've got the concept of
the multiverse colliding with your
universe and deciding which multiverses
to take out maybe taking out the fox
universe in one giant event deciding to
save the mcu at the cost of the fox
universe
but what did you guys not notice that
they have a new logo i mean that's
they're really i love theirs that's what
i want to talk about
are bananas like the i didn't expect as
much like horror as feels like
terrifying well yeah i mean i that's
something that was teased for us a lot
we have this thing with dr strange and
it seems like they're setting up that he
is responsible for a lot of the chaos
that is happening while also wanda
has her own tampering going on as well
so it seems like that when wanda is
recruited or asked by strange to join in
on whatever this chaos is that she's
going to find it as an entry way to get
what she really ultimately wants like
you know i think there's a reason why
she brings a vids again i think there's
a reason why we're going back to the
house in one division you know like
she's gonna go see herself it could be a
psychological projection i didn't think
a lot of people really liked but then
the main hole that people were trying to
point at me was that saying that normal
mutants could have already happened it
could have been some wanda variant but
they were like but she's a nexus being
the only our
r wanda could be the one who could do
that no other variant could do that but
here she is hopping around with other
ones exactly she's acting in with
another wanda so i mean are we looking
at a scarlet like a different scarlet
witch at this moment we're also you know
on mount wondagor which is very famously
a threshold that's close to magic on the
earth so if there was any tampering with
other things that's where you'd want to
do it that's where you'd mess around
with centerac that's where you'd mess
around with chaos magic and you've also
got the idea of it looks like strange
doing another spell that causes problems
not the no way home one just one it was
one smell
that's really going to explore the
capabilities of chaos magic and the
repercussions that it could have
stretching across dimensions and
universes this looks like it's going to
really deliver to the point where i'm a
little bit concerned if it's going to be
too much of a cacophony of chaos
it feels like no way home was the end of
something that was 20 years in the
making this feels like the launch of
something that's going to be the rest of
phase four five and beyond so is this
something that's so big that it's going
to be irreparable like is this tearing
something will this end and have us go
like okay much like loki ended now we
begin like how many beginnings are there
well you see it like i'm excited that
michael waldron is returning to wright
for this because he wrote the loki
series and i thought he did an amazing
job loki's a lot of people's favorite
disney plush show i i really love the
hell out of it especially its sci-fi
existential psychological discussions
that it would have and i'm hoping a lot
of that actually does remain here
because right now i'm like do we only
have time for a bunch of action scenes
because that's what you're going to show
in this training sure sure exactly and
that is like that was my concern as soon
as it ended i was like that's a lot but
if you've got the the market we have
right now especially in a post no way
home world what else do you show except
for like we're just getting started like
they should have better than i thought
they would
yeah yeah i'm surprised they they let us
hear professor x's voice there's a
mutant in the mcu in this trailer they
that's a confirmation who else would it
be i feel like that nexus being thing
you guys are trying to point in a hole
in it
how would you how would you communicate
i would i would posit that that is a
concept that was just as
feeble as what we saw with the infinity
gyms because hey things evolve things
change so i like your concept but uh
it looks to me like it's wrong
and we all know how much marvel loves to
take things from the comic books and
then when they put them in the movies
they change them around yeah
they were miracle children they weren't
called mutants you can't like decide
something for sure because this is
another universe this is another
multiverse yeah you can't compare the
rules of the comics to the rules of the
movies so i wouldn't see her interacting
with another version of herself that
would seem like variants of wanda
confirmed the way elizabeth olsen's
performance is at the end i'm like that
doesn't feel unless that is our version
of wanda who has evolved into something
much darker by that point in the movie
you know i said jesus
yeah i said years and years ago the best
way to bring in the x-men was to do
something kills the fox universe like in
the comics they do blank kills the blank
and i think at the end of the day an
incursion event with the illuminati
destroying the fox universe folding over
things you want bringing in the
characters you want or not this is the
best way to do it if that's what they're
doing they were talking about when
you're when you're hopping around the
universe or something that wanda says
that you're like a hero and there's like
a statue so one universe strange is
really hailed as like you are sorcerer
supreme we love you and that was the
grief versus heroism we were talking
about his perception of his choices
versus her perception of her choices
yeah yeah deep [ __ ] right and
let's go circus let's go circle it up
this visual effects were awesome tiny
new fonts dr strange on the surface
the minotaur we were hearing rumors that
maybe there could be a character rich
raw who could appear in here you didn't
see a face shot so i don't know maybe
also it wasn't really green enough for
me but hey it's a different universe oh
yeah they can fix that if you complain
loud enough guys that's how the internet
works yell about the color what did you
think about this trailer uh this was
more epic than i anticipated it to be
like i was kind of surprised by how much
they showed us here they showed us so
much they showed us like act one two and
three it feels like they did here right
this could be a mislead where this is
the opening and we do get an
encouragement this is the opening not
the opening too much guys big open no
the first two acts i think this could be
an incursion event movie where you
actually see the marvel universe bring
in daredevil type characters from the
netflix universe and bring in characters
from fox we never thought we'd see we
could see nick cage ghost rider in here
this could be all the things because
what you could do is you could literally
have snapshots of different universes
all at once you could have howard the
duck from george lucas like you could
literally do 1986 through today you
could do tv and film and have it be just
little cameos to appease the people that
want that but still tell the story that
is as in-depth as we were trying to make
this that you disagree with you know
there was no point in you showing up to
your kids there's none no incursion
events they're coming no value
just had an initial thought for this
post-credit scene america chavez doesn't
use magic she actually has portal-based
abilities so maybe the way we're able to
stabilize this universe at the end isn't
necessarily through the abilities of the
illuminati at an incursion level event
what if we're able to stabilize because
we use portals to go into other
universes saving individuals and also
that might be the way we bring in
characters from other multiverses safely
instead of crashing them together what
if america chavez is our great savior in
this we saw a bunch in the trailer more
than i expected hoping america chavez is
the one that saves the day
all right guys leave your thoughts down
below follow koi if you can
wow that was overwhelming